bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo un trailer pour le film
The Marvel's vient de nous être partagé
en vrai c'est assez tôt pour nous
proposer un trailer puisque le film a
été décalé pour le 10 novembre mais je
pense que c'est pour nous
IP dans la durée et créer l'attente
comme il le faisait à l'époque en fait
au vu des récentes critiques qui ont été
émises à l'encontre de certaines
productions Marvel a dû revoir sa
stratégie sa communication et notamment
le contenu qu'il nous propose et chose
dont on a déjà beaucoup parlé sur la
chaîne mais la phase 4 c'était la mise
en place de plusieurs concepts etc là la
phase 5 qui vient tout juste de débuter
c'est censé être la mise en place et la
réunion des éléments instaurés the
Marvel je pense personnellement que
c'est un film important pour Marvel
studio car c'est censé être le premier
véritable grand crossover après la phase
4 et du coup je pense qu'ils vont
beaucoup miser dessus on ne s'en rend
pas forcément compte mais the Marvel's
est censé être le point culminant et de
réunion à la fois Wanda vision avec
Monica Rambo la série Miss Marvel Secret
Invasion qui n'est pas encore sorti et
du coup le film Captain Marvel c'est le
premier crossover de la saga du
multivers et qui va se servir de
plusieurs éléments qui ont été instaurés
dans la phase 4 bref maintenant que
cette base est posée intéressons-nous au
trailer et voyons ce qu'il nous propose
premier élément intéressant le trailer
s'ouvre en nous montrant Nick Fiori et
Monica Rambo en train d'effectuer des
recherches dans une base spatiale en
orbite autour de la Terre bon bien
évidemment cela fait déjà écho à la
scène post générique de far from home ou
Nick Fiori nous été désormais montré en
opération dans l'espace mais également à
la fin de Wanda vision ou Monica Rambo
avait été approché des scrolls pour
rejoindre Fiori là haut néanmoins
détails que je trouve pertinent de
souligner c'est que leur base spatiale
est désignée comme le saber je m'y
attarde car vous le savez Nick Fiori est
à l'origine le créateur du SHIELD qui
défend la planète face aux menaces
externes provenant de l'espace et dans
Wanda vision nous avons eu l'avènement
du Sword qui a été fondé par Maria Rambo
la mère de Monica est très certainement
en collaboration avec Nick Fiori vu
qu'elle était l'une de ses proches sauf
que si vous vous rappelez des événements
de Wanda vision suite à la mort de Maria
c'est Award qui avait repris la
direction du Sword et ce dernier avait
causé pas mal d'ennuis par conséquent je
pense perso que Nick Fiori avec Monica
on refondait ce dernier et l'ont
rebaptisé cyber cyber signifiant sabre
on reste quand même dans le délire de
swords l'épée mais également cyber est
une organisation qui n'existe pas dans
les comics contrairement au Sword et au
SHIELD donc cela permet d'appuyer cette
idée par la suite le trailer nous montre
ce qui semble être l'élément
perturbateur du film l'échange de place
à cause des pouvoirs entremêler mais
c'est quelque chose d'A difficile à
traiter car nous n'avons aucune
information nous sommes que dans de la
pure spéculation laissez-moi alors
essayer de vous proposer ma vision des
choses concernant ce concept bon déjà il
est clair qu'il y a une facilité à
relier notre héroïnes par le biais de ce
procédé car ces dernières ont toutes des
pouvoirs reliés à la lumière comme nous
le confirme Monica la jeune femme est
capable de manipuler les rayons lumineux
mais également grâce à ça de convertir
sa masse corporelle chose qui est
montrée dans le trailer et qui avait été
utilisé dans Wanda vision Miss Marvel
quant à elle est une adolescente en
possession du gène mutant mais surtout
elle est une hybride dont l'origine
vient de la dimension Nour Nour qui
signifie lumière ce qui fait qu'elle est
en capacité de créer des formes
lumineuses et tout le tralala qui va
avec puis Carol denverse à cause de
l'explosion du moteur
supraluminicri alimenté par le Tesseract
l'une des pierres d'infinité
manière débordent désormais d'énergie et
de lumière et par ailleurs tout ça va
permettre également à nos héroïnes de se
retrouver et où d’apprendre à se
connaître car Monica possédait une
relation toute particulière avec Captain
Marvel quand elle était enfant puisque
sa mère Maria était la meilleure amie de
Carole néanmoins Monica est désormais
adulte et Carole n'est jamais revenue
sur Terre à part pour les événements
d'Avengers endgame mais bon ce sont des
événements qui se sont déroulés dans le
plus grand des secrets donc en gros ça
fait plus de 30 ans que Monica n'a pas
vu Carole pas sûr du coup que leur
relation soit au beau fixe au début du
film vu que Maria est décédé du coup
sans jamais avoir revu sa meilleure amie
et que Monica dont la source
d'inspiration était carole a été
délaissée par cette dernière cependant
de l'autre côté il sera intéressant de
voir la place que prendra Kamala dans ce
trio puisque tout comme Monica était
enfant elle est fan de Captain Marvel
c'est un élément qui vous permettra
pourquoi pas d'amener quelques querelles
entre les héroïnes leur permettant de
briser la glace et de s'unir mais bref
revenons sur les pouvoirs entremêler
comment expliquer cet événement
personnellement je mise sur le bracelet
de Kamala pourquoi cela tout d'abord on
en avait parlé à la fin de la série mais
le bracelet de Kamala est à très forte
chance une inspiration des comics avec
les fameux bracelets reliés à la Zone
Négative surtout que ces derniers en
plus permettent à ses porteurs
d'échanger de place mais cela ne
s'arrête pas là si on regarde bien le
trailer outre les tentatives de
manipulation visuelle que Marvel fait à
chaque bande-annonce ses kamalas qui
étaient les portées à chaque fois et qui
est la cause des échanges de place quand
Monica est dans l'espace c'est Kamala
qui arrive à sa place quand Kamala veut
montrer ses pouvoirs elle échange de
place avec Carole et lors du combat de
fin Kamala échange encore une fois de
place avec Monica néanmoins encore du
troublant si on se rappelle de la scène
de fin de la série Miss Marvel le
bracelet de Kamala c'était éveillé tout
seul pour à terme nous montrer l'échange
avec Carole comme si le bracelet était
autosuffisant ou était pourquoi pas
manipuler à distance et là cela va nous
permettre de rebondir sur un autre point
comme des volets dans la courte série
dédiée à Kamala il existe normalement
deux bracelets sauf que tout le long de
l'épopée nous n'en avions qu'un seul et
pire que ça quand Aïcha
l'arrière-grand-mère de Kamala avait
découvert le bracelet ce dernier était
sur le bras d'un être qui s'apparentait
un cri je pense que vous voyez où je
veux en venir mais dans le trailer nous
avons enfin la révélation de la future
grande antagoniste du film Dar ben alors
dans les comics Dar ben on en avait déjà
parlé mais c'est un peu nobody tiers
c'est un personnage très peu connu qui
apparaît très peu de fois donc il y aura
très peu d'inspiration provenant de
là-bas néanmoins la seule chose qu'il
faut retenir c'est que normalement c'est
un général cri dans son adaptation pour
le MCU il y a des choses très
intéressantes à souligner Dar ben semble
être en quelque sorte la nouvelle
dirigeante décrits et pour cause
l'intelligence suprême a été surpassée
par Captain Marvel durant son film mais
surtout cette dernière est en possession
de la même arme que possédait autrefois
le défunt Ronan l'accusateur ce qui
traduit que Dar ben symbolise la relève
de ce dernier surtout qu'après les
événements de Captain Marvel et la mort
de Ronan l'Empire crie a pas mal été
ébranlé donc Dar ben nous amènerait un
nouveau souffle pour ce peuple et nous
montrerait les changements qui ont été
apportés mais pour revenir à ce que je
disais plus tôt nous sommes témoins que
Dar ben en plus de l'arme des
accusateurs possèdent également un
bracelet semblable à celui de Kamala il
y a pour moi de très très fortes chances
qu'il s'agisse du second bracelet qui
complète celui de Miss Marvel et par
conséquent cela pourrait expliquer
certaines choses le film the Marvel
étant centré sur trois personnages
principaux cela veut dire que le
long-métrage doit avancer le récit de
chacun et par conséquent conclure ce qui
avait été introduit dans les dernières
productions pour appréhender du coup la
suite et l'avenir et pour moi Dar ben
pourrait permettre tout ça premièrement
par rapport à Carole Captain Marvel a
véritablement fragilisé l'Empire cri et
continue encore aujourd'hui elle est
devenue l'une des plus grandes ennemies
de ces derniers donc pour moi il y a de
très grandes chances que Dar ben soit la
raison de toutes les perturbations du
film pour faire tomber Carole ensuite
par rapport à Monica la menace que
symbolise Dar ben lui permettrait de
prendre conscience de pourquoi Carole
vagabonde dans l'espace depuis plus de
30 ans les cris sont un peuple
véritablement dangereux et par le biais
du cyber cela peut être la prise de
conscience que l'humanité doit se
préparer à se défendre face à ces
derniers comme dans les comics avec la
fameuse guerre cris et scroll et enfin
le plus important par rapport à Kamala
darbé ne va nous amener des réponses
quant à l'origine des bracelets en fait
de par l'inspiration des comics il y a
de très très grandes chances que les
deux bracelets soient issus de la
technologie crie et également on sait
que c'est en lien avec la dimension
lourd dimension lourde qui est l'étape
suivante pour Kamala puisque l'ouverture
de la dimension était l'un des objectifs
de sa série en fait on pourrait encore
retourner dans des explications et des
inspirations profondes comme je vous
avais déjà fait dans une vidéo passée
mais ce qu'il faut retenir ici c'est
qu'il semblerait que les clandestins
avec la dimension lourd soit relié à la
race des cris et notamment par le biais
des bracelets qui sont la clé pour
ouvrir l'accès à la dimension après
avoir où ça nous mènera comme je vous ai
dit nous avons très peu d'informations
et nous aurons bien évidemment
l'occasion de théoriser dans les mois à
venir enfin le trou que Monica et Fiori
sont en train d’analyser pour moi cela
peut être une simple facilité
scénaristique permettant de relier les
personnages à Carole qui voyage dans les
tréfonds de l'univers de quoi améliorer
les déplacements en gros etc mais je
pense que cela peut être également une
anomalie déclenchée par un événement
cosmique et c'est fortement possible que
ce soit en lien avec les cris et puis on
n'a pas parlé du fameux aspect comédie
musicale qui est attendu dans le film le
trailer vient nous apporter des réponses
là-dessus durant le film nos héroïnes
vont voyager vers une planète du nom
d'Albana dirigé par le prince Yann
l'aspect comédie musicale pourrait venir
de la bas puisque nous sommes témoin que
les gens de cette planète danse et
chantent mais dans tous les cas cette
planète sera certainement un point
central du film puisque nos héroïnes et
l'Empire crie avec Dar ben
s'affronteront là-bas et à noter qu'au
vu de leur tenue il y a de grandes
chances que Kamala Monica et Carole
récupère leur costume
issus des comics là-bas
et voilà je pense que l'on va s'arrêter
ici pour cette analyse de trailer comme
je vous disais toute façon nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler car il y a
énormément de zones d'ombre il y aura
également d'autres trailers et surtout
j'ai envie de le préciser mais je pense
que Marvel studio mise beaucoup sur ce
film car il va nous proposer le premier
véritable grand crossover de la saga du
multivers à vous de me dire si vous êtes
IP ou non en commentaire moi
personnellement cela me donne pas mal
envie je reste assez curieux et j'ai
vraiment envie de voir ce qu'ils vont
nous proposer par rapport au cri et
surtout les bracelets ça se trouve ce
sont juste des artefacts futuristes
provenant du 41e siècle ramener dans le
passé à cause des voyages de Kang je dis
ça pour le troll enfin quoi que bref
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleu et surtout à vous abonner à la
chaîne que le lionhar soit avec vous les
amis c'était Argo rock allez ciao tout
le monde
[Musique]